I'm just going to shut her down
everywhere in this fight everyone is
going to see the best version of me
welcome
[Music]
the trilogy match we've all been waiting
for
right through the city like British
[Music]
if you ain't thick please don't get
involved
now Brandon
what is
what up kids it is Monday September 26th
uh summer's officially over but nobody
told California California is like now
we're gonna stay in the Hondos we're
gonna keep it hot global warming holler
um what's going on fam good to see you
how's everybody you guys good great
grand wonderful good to see everybody
out there thanks for tuning in thank you
for watching your boys fresh off the
plane from my hometown of Denver
Colorado was out there on a more somber
note my grandma passed away but she was
98 and uh there's humor even at a
funeral because my dad goes Gone Too
Soon and then I made a joke and it
really went well with the family I
thought it was gonna eat [ __ ] at a
funeral but it went well
so uh it was good though because my
dad's one of 11 kids one of 11 and uh
all the grandkids all the great
grandkids you're talking about over just
a room full of goddamn probably 80 to
100 jobs a lot of shops we all look
exactly the same everybody looked
exactly the same very strange
um made me realize I need to get back
more and
connect with my family more saw my mama
saw my mama
um
she fell down stairs and uh has a spiral
fracture on her leg uh her entire leg
like shattered so let's put bolts and
screws and all that [ __ ] and please turn
your phone off Mark
um so my mom gets the spiral fracture
which she's had for a while the funny
thing is she goes to this doctor right
and they put her under anesthesia and
she woke up and was like oh thank God
that's over and like actually it's not
[ __ ] up you have these blisters on
your feet so
um we can't do the surgery we didn't see
the blisters before I guess if that
happens like three percent of people and
get these blisters they can't do the
surgery to the blisters are gone so they
put it under
it all the anesthesia think about that
you didn't already put her under shave
the leg get the leg all with all that
brown [ __ ] and the doctor comes like oh
well there's all these blisters because
the break it does something to the skin
on the foot and if you have these
blisters they can't perform the surgery
unless the blisters are healed so she
woke up I was like oh man thank God
that's done I'm glad I'm over it and
like here's the thing you have to wait
about another three weeks before we do
the surgery we have to put you back on
and we [ __ ] up so she eventually got
the surgery so I'm there my mom's balls
deep in podcasts and listen to all my
podcast breaks up for this one she's not
a big fight fan but she listened to find
a kid King The Sting fight campaigns all
that [ __ ] so she knows the flow and
she's just talking about you know she's
like I'm so sad sad Theo's gone and
thank God for Delia and she loves Chris
and she loves Brian fighting the kid and
then uh she's like well tell me what's
going on the business like business as
usual Mama business as usual and she's
like oh that's cool that's cool and then
she and I go with you know touring picks
up next week and Mom I'm on the road
like six weeks in a row I start in
Boston she goes is that Mark Harley
gonna be with you I'm like
yeah he's yeah he's always on the road
man I'm just all social media and
security and you know have him around
all the time that's my guy she goes oh
I'm telling you man if you brought him
here
the things I I went whoa whoa whoa whoa
first of all stop because I'm gonna get
my phone out
all right keep that same energy I said
Mama do I want you to say this exact
[ __ ] but let me go through my dates
first to promote my dates and then you
say this she's like okay then I get the
phone out and this is my mom
um you know hitting on Mark Harley
what's up fam out in uh Denver visiting
I literally just got there by the way
you guys should know your boy's hitting
the road after I leave uh my hometown
here in Denver I'm in Boston next week
next Thursday okay Saturday Boston live
Boston then after that October 13th
through the 15th I'm in San Jose come
get some San Jose then right after that
I am in Salt Lake City Utah Wise Guys
are my favorite then I end the tour and
September I'm sorry in October in
Calgary Calgary's the 27th and 28th come
get some Calgary thickboy.com
hey Brett so is Mark Harley gonna be
there too with you I mean yeah he's on
the road oh my God he is such a stud
muffin Mark I have a broken ankle right
now but if you were here and I didn't
have this broken ankle I'd be jumping
all over you boy oh okay I gotta come
visit why'd you say boy
this is weird I see you guys out there
I'll be jumping all over you boy I was
like why you say boy I know my mom's
hilarious my mom's so funny man
yeah look at that man shot up remark is
getting married tiger think the official
whiskey of the freaking uh
wedding for Aubry Marcus The Savage the
brain and power behind
um on it
obvious been a good friend for a long
freaking time man he's crushing it yeah
just laser tag with the kiddos yesterday
um God man I had to light these little
basters up I had to light them up man so
Boston because he's too little so
originally I was gonna play it's Tiger's
friend's birthday right and so there's
like whatever 10 kids and some of the
parents and so uh I was like yo boss you
wanna do he's like yeah I'm like it's
dark and the man it might be scary and
the lady running the laser tags like
well you can go with him just hold him
he can fire the gun I was like okay I
was like well who wears the vest she's
like well you have to wear the vest
we'll have that vest for two-year-olds
I'm like I'll wear the vest uh literally
little do they know that
um my daycare was [ __ ] laser tag
called Laser Quest in Aurora Colorado
shout out to Laser Quest and bossy would
just keep pulling the trigger keep
pulling the trigger and uh tiger was on
the opposite team with his friends dude
I didn't realize how bad we're beating
the [ __ ] out all these little kids we
scored 80 points the next closest was
20. and I could and I knew like probably
towards the end I saw the lady run it
she goes she goes hey Dad hey Dad oh
boom boom boom boom and because I'm tall
so I can get over the thing up they
can't hit me but because Boston was on
the thing I go dude I just hold him over
and go get him get him and they're
trying to get us I'll just pull him back
then we wait get him get him get him and
then the lady's like hey hey Dad let's
take it down a notch and then they bring
up the score at the end it's all you
know whatever you know Boston 89.
my girl's like what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you I'm like well we played a win
[ __ ] play to win gotta teach him play
to win daddy we played to win
and then uh yeah I posted the Croc video
the [ __ ] Crocs man these kids in the
Crocs
let me tell you something have a great
day I'll tell you what really puts a
thorn in my dick go to park kids like
Dad they're saying let's take our shoes
off I'm like yeah give me your shoes
Crocs
crowd together that's not cool it's not
cool at all do I give him a little
leeway but don't wear Crocs right you
guys know this by now don't wear Crocs
they're kids so they'll learn they'll
get a little older maybe first or second
grade and then they're gonna come home
from school I'm like Dad we got roasted
because we wore Crocs to school with
shorts and I say well dress like an
[ __ ] get treated like an [ __ ] dim
the rules dim the rules Daddy all right
dim the rules are you getting ready to
go out on a date then patreon's there
put Austin vanderford wears Crocs daily
they respond unless I love them but
please don't
I mean who just rocks Crocs all the time
dude it's so
disgusting this open you know it's just
[ __ ] you're on a plane too it's like
what the [ __ ] are you doing man they're
all decked out yeah but the thing now
kids tiger I think Tigers is the uh the
bottom on top of the here's the real
colorful
um what do you call tie-dye ones but
they they put these these like uh
stickers I don't know they're not
stickers they're like little uh on pins
it's like a thing they do and there's
all they're all into Pokemon kids love
Pokemon yeah that's lasted forever but
that that thing about yesterday because
it was uh one Tigers best friends my
girl's best friends is Korean so it's
all Kurt you would have loved it there's
just tons of crazy people and me just
[ __ ] Godzilla the white guy and uh
there's a Pokemon themed and obviously I
was looking around every Pokemon
cupcakes Pokemon gift baskets everything
Pokemon Pokemon I think holy Pokemon's
making Bang dude they've been relevant
forever and then kids aren't even
they're not really into like trading
cards as far as like football or
basketball or baseball like I grew up
with it's all Pokemon and they don't age
you know what I'm saying they don't age
it's poke is Pokemon a Japanese thing
yeah that's what I thought yeah and of
course his friend had these Pokemon
Converse on my son's like man where do
you get though somebody let me look dude
some special drop Converse did to
[ __ ] get them stupid Pokemon
um yeah man
all right kids let's take a little break
from me chatting your ear off about the
fight game Boss now see this Thursday
Friday Saturday Boston come get
something in San Jose October 13th
through the 15th tickets at thickboy.com
all right
I'll tell you what now let's get a
little word in from our sponsor
betterhelp cause you gotta it's tough to
train your brain all right it's very
tough to train your brain to stain
problem solving mode right when you're
faced with a challenge in life when
you're all stressed out you're like man
how am I gonna figure this out you don't
need to be all on your own man it's not
a one-man Army here or one woman Army
for that matter you can get some help
from professionals all right you can get
some real help with a therapist all
right and you can help you become a
better person better Problem Solver
making it easier accomplish your goals
no matter how big or small all right if
you're thinking of giving therapy a try
better help is a great freaking option
it's convenient it's super easy to get
done it's affordable it's all online you
get matched with a therapist after
filling out a brief survey and switch
therapists at any time if you're not
vibing with your therapist say less
they're gonna switch it up for you so
you get what you need exactly from
better help man when you wanna when you
want to be a better Problem Solver
therapy can get you there because you
can get a licensed professional help you
navigate through all all the weeds of
Life man you don't need to do it on your
own anymore because there's better help
betterhelp.com shop schab get 10 off
your first month that's betterhelp help
help.com shop Schaub betterhelp.com shop
you ever ask yourself uh how long have I
had this mattress I've been sleeping on
and think how much you sleep dude think
how much you guys you bros you ladies
are sleeping all the time you're
spending a third of your life in bed and
you've had the same mattress since
College yeah man you don't even think
about it it's like it's comfy is it
though are there better mattresses there
are that's why my friends at Helix sleep
it's a premium mattress brand that
provides Taylor mattresses all right
that are made for you based on your
thick body the yeah match Seam for the
kiddos and it's custom mattresses that
are built they're personalized and
shipped straight to your door free of
charge all right yeah all you gotta do
is take the Helix sleep quiz and find
your perfect mattress in under two
minutes are you side sleeper
bottom sleeper you sleep on your stomach
your side all hot cold whatever however
you sleep they got the perfect mattress
just for you I took the Helix sleep quiz
and I was matched with the perfect model
because I I like something a little more
firm I sleep on my side and this
mattress was built just for the way I
sleep I love the bed I'm obsessed with
this bed all right not only is the
mattress the best I've ever slept on but
the setup was super fast and easy Helix
sleep mattresses are delivered in a box
straight to your door for free and
they're also American made they come
with a 10 to 15 year warranty depending
on the model you also get to try it out
100 nights risk-free if you don't love
it I know you will but if you don't they
pick it up and you get a full refund you
got nothing to lose don't want to take
my word for it all right cool Helix has
been awarded the number one mattress
picked by GQ and Wired Magazine all
right people love it Helix is offering
you guys up to 200 rules off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
are the listeners and viewers of this
show the shop show so go to
helixsleep.com that's schab Helix
sleep.com slash job with Helix better
sleep starts now
there's some fights over the weekend
um some fights some good ones the uh the
never ending career of my boy Ben
Henderson did the damn thing
um he got a decision win which he needed
against Peter quilly which is a good win
but kind of the talk of the entire card
was y'all Romero versus Melvin manuf uh
Melvin's last fight
you know if it's not gonna blow your
hair back but that third round once the
ground and pound was ferocious and yo
Romero dude he has to be 40 something
and listen this is a Cuban 40. he might
be 60 for all that you know what I'm
saying like Luis Ortiz the boxer
77 years old I think you know what I'm
saying so for your Romero I mean look at
that body dude it's not so's his traps
dude one of the biggest freaks of all
time ever it has to be top three biggest
freaks to ever compete in MMA I mean he
looks like a linebacker dude he looks
like a linebacker for the goddamn Denver
Broncos
poor Melvin man of they're like hey dude
uh we know it's your last fight so we're
gonna give you the worst matchup
possible is that cool with you he's like
sure why not you know
my age it's 45. and dude and I'll tell
you that's a cube in 45. that 10 years
size by 55 55.
Brian wants to be like oh look at me you
know I'm 55 dude Mel or [ __ ] y'all
Romeo's 55. that's what you're competing
with just a Savage and then uh I think
he said he's gonna go to 85 right once
it once the title shot 85 or light
heavyweight yeah he wants a title shot
they should definitely give it to him
but you look phenomenal man that body
just don't stop that body bro nachos
look at them jacked
so crazy dude the other uh talk of the
weekend for flight wise was Floyd
Mayweather but those are always
skeptical right I think Joe came out
with seeing how it's like a he thinks
it's all like set up like there's an
agreement this one didn't look like that
like there was a decent fight dude you I
watched the fight
you know I watched it a friend of mine
sent me a link
chin but he uh right
but they were these boys were going yeah
that Japanese dude was actually trying
to yeah like because I was watching and
I was gonna make fun of it and like you
know come on here today and kind of
clown Mayweather and stuff but they were
these boys were throwing he was trying
to get them out of there so he's they're
either that that Japanese dude uh
asakira is the greatest actor to ever
enter a ring or these boys were for real
and Floyd's laughing even that Floyd's
age dude look how old Floyd is still
doing the goddamn thing
but Floyd landed that right hand and it
was nasty man nasty
so I you know I don't think it's that
one I do remember you and I attention
for sure we thought me and Rogan argued
about that yeah hard that one was
tension that was super suspect I this is
my thing with this you know but it's
easy money for Floyd you know he did
take a couple hits there but um
if you don't have money problems right
and he hasn't paid Lloyd uh uh Logan
Paul yet right so but if you don't have
money problems why are you doing this
you know what I'm saying it's like I
think he made like eight million here
which to him is a far cry from his
Heyday but it's like that's a ton of
money talking around that's a [ __ ] ton
of money but if you're Floyd you have
all these Bugattis and you know anything
about Bugatti just the maintenance on a
Bugatti is about 60 to 80 grand a year
just and you can't take it to a shop you
have to fly the car back to [ __ ]
France you have to fly that car to
Europe to change oil Tire changes it's
looking like 60 Grand just in service
not to mention the the surcharge to fly
it over there you know house it get it
over there it's a nightmare yeah and he
has so many Bugattis and you know he
says you don't need money to need to
fight but then when he watches like why
what's going on here dude the easy money
I mean that one wasn't that easy but to
make I guess it was 20 to 30. that's
what they're saying here
it's weird right yeah I I understand we
get it the nut thing I I get that though
during his pro career Mayweather earn up
to 300 million dollars per fight and so
now he's doing this for five six eight
million they're saying me 30 million I
heard it was 8 million
and that's strange though
it's strange but I get it if you have
all that crap you got to pay for it
unless it's all paid off which I doubt
yeah but you would think you know
if so he's uh his career earnings in and
out of box have total up to about 1.1
billion dollars
you know how do I do it man I know why
do it
because if you have the love for boxing
with State competing in boxing like uh
Bernard Hopkins did right
but you know I guess this spectacle and
people pay for it it's just strange to
me a little strange you know his uh his
boy also fought too I have a security
guard yeah he got he got knocked out
knocked out
fedor's brother thought yep he got
knocked out too that was like the battle
of the bad boys that guy the guy he
fought I don't know if you guys know
this Mark in case he's so the so uh
fedor's brother he got in trouble he
went to prison he's supposed to get I
think six years because he
raped and took hostage of a housekeeper
and then the guy that he and then he
only did like 18 months because it's
Russia right so Fedor called his brother
called him was like Hey listen you gotta
get him out here was like say less so
they put him back out
but then uh the gentleman that he fought
was in prison for I forget exactly a
bunch of [ __ ] and a bunch of [ __ ] like
some really bad [ __ ] and it like was
diagnosed basically crazy like schizo
schizophrenic like guy has some issues
call him Redbeard but he brought he'd
[ __ ] Molly wopped yep Pharaoh's
brother
Alexander yeah Molly want them face
plant is bad opening fight too oh like
right away for seconds yep like yeah 30
seconds
you know battle the bad boys there
it goes here it is
boom loopy loopy left hook right on the
chin
you
whoop right here
boom
Cashland right behind the chin air there
bad knockout though yeah whenever I see
left hooks it doesn't seem like when I
try to throw it just for yeah that's
like my weakest possible thing but
everyone like it so you guys are good at
it man it's all about timing too
well this weekend's uh better fights
yeah better fights this weekend you got
a UFC it's not gonna blow your hair back
but at least the girl Mackenzie Dern's
fighting I'm never mad at Mackenzie
turns fighting uh she's fighting uh yawn
Yan uh the Chinese Powerhouse there
you know John coming off two losses
Mackenzie during but they have the
common loss in uh Rodriguez so I get it
yeah John listen yon's on a two-fight
losing skid there but she lost to the
champ Carlos sparza she got TKO and then
Split Decision Marina Rodriguez so you
know nothing to hang ahead about but we
always root for a Mackenzie during here
probably the I mean definitely top five
best looking female Fighters are
fighting this weekend Mackenzie darn up
there Angela Lee up yeah
um out of all the cards though I'm more
excited I'm most excited I just I should
say for the one Championship now it's on
in Singapore Friday night if you want to
watch it
um early but it's on
on One Prime video
that's Saturday at let's see eight a
eight a.m Singapore time which is what
time our time's going I think we did
what has to be what has because because
it's on One Prime they're trying to do
it so it's prime time so I'd assume
around six or seven Pacific because they
want to do it at the the same time
so it is the next day at 5 PM I'm
guessing
so 5 p.m yeah so Prime Time really by
the time the main card yeah there you go
and uh you have
I'd say my favorite fire in one
Championship Angela Lee fighting the
[ __ ] punching Panda the greatest
nickname of all of sports the punching
Panda Nan
she's a Savage now she's the champ at
straw weight right and she's fighting
Angela Lee this is the rubber match
because uh this is their third fight and
they have a history there and
um Angeli's beater before in the Lost
tour but Angela lost her going up in
weight so now uh the punching Panda has
to come down and meet Angela Lee at her
natural weight so
um should be a good fight and I don't
know if you've seen the punching Panda
this she is a punching Panda she knocks
girls out knocks them out dude it's a
good fight but even the fight that Angel
Lee lost against the punching Panda she
was kind of whooping her ass she had her
in an awful submission but the punching
Panda wouldn't give give it up so Angela
Lee put all her effort into finishing
her and then the bell rang and then she
was gash put all her effort into Fisher
now Angela to Angela to Angela Lee's
defense she did come up and wait so if
Angela wins this should be the should
become a double champ
you know but they have a history there
man the whole card's fun though it kicks
off their heavyweight kickboxing World
Grand Prix and then the thing listen I'm
always excited when Angela fights but
what I you know I love Jiu Jitsu
um they're they're doing the first ever
uh flyweight submission grappling
championship against Mikey
mushushimi
mushumishi mushumishi nah don't judge a
book by its cover if you don't know this
gentleman he was on Rogan
um he's kind of you know for lack of a
better word and kind of a nerdy dude but
straight [ __ ] Savage
Savage will read freaking Lord of the
Rings then snap your neck that's Mikey
dude he's a Savage and he's uh it's dude
what's dope about it is I don't think
jitsu's ever been on this level on this
big of a car this mainstream of card
it's a flyweight submission uh grappling
World title fight and Mikey vs Cleaver
Souza who they fought before they're one
and one Mikey beat him the first time uh
or did Mikey be him the first time or
second time I think he's Mikey uh beat
him the first time lost the second time
and uh he it's one of his he says it's
one of his hardest matches ever so it'll
be a good fight and their second one
which he lost on points I think it was
either 2017 was like grappling match of
the year it was ridiculous
so it should be dope man should be dope
just to highlight Jiu Jitsu you know
what I'm saying it's a big deal man it's
a big freaking deal
really big deal
yeah so they're one-on-one so yeah
common theme here you got these Trilogy
fights going on
yeah my kid's just such a Savage so
Mikey and Souza initially face each
other as black belts at the quarter
finals 2017. I think that was the match
of the Year both men were World Champs
in brown belt category at the time
both comparable go okay
[Music]
all right head into the final minutes of
the contests
um Souza each straight a pair of sweeps
to even score four four but machinis
early submission attack had earned him
an advantage put him ahead
it's just dope for jiu jitsu be on this
level it's really cool yeah it's great
that he was on Rogan too because people
people love that kid
yeah when me and Mark went to the press
conference he's just you know super
humble
you know just a just a cool kid people
can look up to especially for jiu jitsu
you look at him you're like oh man that
guy's that famous in making that much
money doing Jiu Jitsu you know because
he doesn't look like LeBron James
so I'm sure a lot of people can relate
to him he's a Savage man
but that is uh what do we say Saturday
night 5 p.m
one on prime prime Amazon Prime video
it's the second one remember the first
one was uh uh Mighty Mouse
where he won so
Singapore indoor Stadium it's gonna be
dope man it's gonna be really dope
I'm looking most forward to the one
Championship they got Bellator two
bellator's card is pretty stacked It's
on Showtime shot to show time you got
Patricio pitbull versus Adam BoRics it's
a huge fight for Adam pork some room for
Adam borks there you got AJ McKee Spike
Carlisle AJ McKee always a fan of uh
he's been on food truck then he got my
my boy
I leave him the LeBron James of MMA
Aaron Picos fighting Jeremy Kennedy then
he got Juan Archuleta who's also my boy
fighting Enrique barzola and then even
the prelims are pretty tasty got JJ
Wilson you got my camel Nick Brown It's
a pretty solid card I'll take it
that's on Showtime
good fights let's take a little break
let's take a little break from me
chatting here off about the fight world
because guys I'm worried about your
wieners that's right there's one thing
that as people always said about me is
Brendan cares about your wiener I care
about your wieners out there guys and I
feel like a lot of you could use a
little confidence all right a little
boost in the bedroom that's where my
friends at Bluetooth comes on in the
bedroom not a weird way no man Bluetooth
is a unique online service that delivers
the same active ingredients as Viagra
and Cialis but in chewable tablets it's
a fraction of the cost take them any
time day night can plan ahead or be
ready to go when it's time to go super
simple all you gotta do is sign up at
bluechoo.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers once you're
approved you'll receive your
prescription within days best part it's
all online you don't have to visit the
doctor office no awkward conversations
no way in line at the pharmacy delivered
straight to your door discreet little
package right listen Bluetooth they're
made in the U.S of prepared and Ship
Direct to your freaking door so if you
could benefit from a little extra boost
in the bedroom when it's time to go if
you know what I'm talking about
Bluetooth can help you out chew it and
do it baby and I got a special deal for
all the shop show viewers and listeners
try Bluetooth free when you use the
promo code shop schab just pay five
dollars shipping that's bluetooth.com
promo code shop to receive your first
month free visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
and I thank Bluetooth for being part of
this podcast
last ad then we get back to the program
kids you know those times when you're in
the zone when you're in the Flow State
and just knocking things out like man if
I was like this all the time I'd be the
next Elon Musk well you can be like that
all the time what if I told you this
little pill a little all-natural pill
that's gonna get you there a nootropic
right to get in that flow State whenever
you need it I'm talking about Alpha
Brain if you haven't heard of Alpha
Brain what planet are you living on not
this one because Alpha Brain from audit
is the ultimate way to get in the Flow
State all right if you want to try some
Alpha Brain or you're talking about the
renowned nootropic supplement from my
friends that own it they've sold over 1
million bottles all right over one
million dude Alpha Brain promotes
cognitive functions include memory
mental speed and focus can help you
remember names I use it at my grandma's
funeral I was just freaking dicing out
names everything was just hot off my
tongue I was like this is insane
everyone's like oh my God your brain you
don't have CT I'm like I do but it's
Alpha brain kids that's right man uh my
boy Joe Rogan says it helps them form
better sentences when he's talking that
guy knows a thing or two about talking
be more like Joe Rogan Alpha Brain
contains all the stuff you need to get
your brain firing all cylinders and
you're like well is there caffeine
involved because I can't even drink
coffee or energy drinks nope caffeine
free baby all right and here's the thing
if you don't if you want to try Alpha
Brain you don't like it get your money
back just give them two weeks and if
that point you don't love it all right
Alpha Brain just isn't for you tell them
why they refund your money you got
nothing to lose no return necessary save
up 10 on your order by going to
audit.com
that's on it.com for 10 off Alpha Brain
or anything else you see on their
website I swear by their total gut
health their multivitamin their krill
oil they had kettlebells they got it all
man but Alpha Brain is the ride or die
and if you don't want to use my link
just go to your local Walmart all right
go to Walmart and get it but also help
your boy out go to honor.com shop schab
your 10 off Alpha Brain now let's get
back to the program what does she got
alrighty tomorrow dude we gotta if you
if you haven't listened to the last food
truck with Chris Barnett
um Beast Boy it's my
top three it's not say favorite it's
[ __ ] up there man the the Beast Boy
and just how good of a person his energy
is insane he sent me a text this morning
I was like dude I've gotten so much
great feedback man thank you so much I'm
like it's all human I know I did nothing
you guys both did it but he's so lovable
oh my God yeah that dude just has it man
he just has that it Factor he can't help
but root for the guy uh but we have a
we have a another big guest on this week
and I'm excited for that one I won't say
who it is I don't like to say the guest
before they come on because sometimes
that jinx it but uh here's a fight this
week I'll put it that way and he is a
Savage he's one of my favorite Fighters
doing the damn thing and he's coming on
this week and we have Frank Mayer flying
in town tomorrow Frank mayor's flying
town tomorrow we'll do a Fight Night
flashback with him think about his fight
I know he fights forever and then he has
a podcast so I think him and his team's
find it here for me to be on their
podcast so that should be good
hey a big week man I'm in botany for
Boston I think my flight's at 7 A.M on
Thursday Boston's Thursday Friday
Saturday at last Boston those are almost
sold out and then San Jose is October
13th through the 15th Salt Lake City
October 20th through 22nd and I end
October in Calgary Canada October 27th
28th at the Rooftop in Calgary but uh
Boston you're up this week one of my
favorite cities I can't wait it's real
I'm this excited to fly into a city I
love Boston man I can't wait should have
came chin I know I didn't plan it well
enough so yeah Boston's not closed no
it's not I have friends there too really
and my friend she's an attorney and her
husband's a judge and they watch our
stuff too oh damn yeah shout out to them
might need them yeah I'll let them know
how to show them I need them in the
future
what do you got all right so this
happened at Bellator
um I don't know if you've ever seen this
truck before I guess it's a reverse arm
triangle let me see it how do you how'd
they get that I don't even know
so he's grabbing his thigh I assume
there
it's kind of hard to even tell what's
happening here but that guy in bottom I
wish I wish they'd let it go I'm curious
how he got into that position
no he's out yeah yeah he's out
come on ref
I'm curious where that guy's uh oh wow
he's out I know
I wanna did he go inside the thigh there
to tighten the grip you know what I'm
saying how the [ __ ] did they get there
oh that is snuggalicious
I mean have you seen that before no sure
I haven't especially in the MMA
some Jiu Jitsu matches I've seen that
happen never an MMA high level MMA like
Bellator never that's a dope ass joke
Chris cyborg had her first boxing match
over the weekend and she beat uh Simone
Silva which she should have been
decision yeah
yeah so that happened
um so Scott Coker
he was doing an interview and he said
that he's in talks with Nate Diaz but
then you saw the yeah yeah
he's close with Nate came out was like
it's actually illegal yeah to
communicate with Nate right now there
can't be any talks going on
so you said yeah his team reached out
and they're in talks and then of course
when that came out with the aerial thing
this is exactly what Ariel said Ariel
put a note on any story about a promoter
promotion talking to Nathan Diaz right
now don't believe it not true it's
actually illegal Diaz is an exclusive
three months negotiation period with the
UFC meaning he can't talk to anyone and
he hasn't talked to anyone yeah they're
not gonna they're just gonna wait to
three months and then Scott Coker said
oh no his team just reached out but that
was it
well so he said talk dialogue going on
but also I know there's a three-month
waiting period trust me they're reaching
out yeah I kind of Imagine they would
just but I mean unless they get like
crazy find or something
Scott Coker as well here's the thing is
that my guys reached out to the
management management camera and said
look he saw some exclusive negotiation
negotiation period
so let's see how that plays out all
right well initially he made it seem
like they're actually talking to Nate
potentially I bet they are but then once
you find out you know there's legal
action you'll see welcome after he's
like well I'm just saying we reached out
we didn't know that was yeah part of the
deal
uh I think you kind of talked about this
a little bit but just uh Floyd
Mayweather came out saying that they're
talking about him and Mayweather I don't
know him and maybe him and Conor
McGregor part two like they're actually
I just need to see the demand for it but
one thing about Floyd he's not full of
[ __ ] so where there's smoke there's fire
so I bet there's something to it and all
the fights he's taking right now for
money so I don't know oh Kevin Holland I
think thick boy fight news covered this
but Kevin Hollins put a post up
insinuating that he's actually done had
a good run 30 in a little over a month
got paid them out next career choice hmm
one should reach out to him get them on
food truck see what's going on there
he'd be great for food truck yeah he's a
character yeah but I wonder after the
homs out one he's like I'm out
so I don't believe it and also this came
up so Daniel Rodriguez is going to be
fighting Neil magni yeah so if someone
said that it has something to do with
that like
he should have fought
one of them and since he died that they
give to Daniel over him something like
that yeah interesting
yeah because
Holland versus Neil mackney is a goddamn
good fight
interesting
yeah there's no way he stays retired
he's just now he started of course not I
mean he has a lot of fights but
but I mean he's just his hype is Big
right now so yeah I mean I don't think
Kim losing a hom's not dementia's star
powered in any facet taking it on a
day's notice
Eddie Alvarez he has parted ways with
one and they said they're on good terms
and everything else but he's looking for
another place to fight
um
so I'm officially a free agent ready to
hunt tell me who's next
underground I'm a grand King yeah I love
Eddie at least one of my favorites he's
such a good dude
um yeah I wonder what he's next ready
he's been doing a hot second man very
long time
prior to
um so Rogan said this on his podcast
that it's in his contract that if Dana
White leaves then he leaves as well
hmm
makes sense I mean him and Dan are very
close you know
so yeah there's no way it's broken to
work for somebody else like if some
suits came and took it over but I mean I
don't think they could control him
either but uh you'd be surprised of
their try and that's when that's why he
would leave you know so that makes sense
though God look at Dana there you know I
mentioned [ __ ] leather jacket
and Joe Rogan with her yeah I know
that makes sense though yeah I mean
they're super close
here's another quick one on Dana not
really fight news related but he went to
a blood place and I guess they can kind
of tell how many years you have to live
do we believe that I don't know I don't
know how good the bottle is the real
thing apparently
I mean have you ever heard of this
before no this is the first time that's
what I was kind of like interested in
this what do we believe more Dana can
take your blood death and blood test and
tells you how long you can live or my
conspiracy on the UFC 279.
right like come on come on I don't know
the songs come on I mean because we'd
all we'd all do it right I wouldn't do
it I would do it if the blood type is
like yo man if you don't change the way
you live you have three days to live
okay in that case yeah yeah you know
what I'm saying like if I would just
tell the doctor he don't give me the
exact thing but if it's like a long time
don't tell me if it's short tell me how
short it says and what I can do to
change that [ __ ] yeah everybody do this
yeah they're like sir you have nicotine
whiskey all sorts of weird [ __ ] in your
body
so Dana said he had 10.4 years to live
if he didn't change
the way his health is
but I'm full of [ __ ] okay you never know
okay yeah I don't know I've never heard
of that yeah but if it's true then
that'd be pretty cool I'm not true
though right right that's a lot of blood
there's not a blood test you can take
that goes you're gonna live 27 years I
think about all blood tests are kind of
like that they just tell you if you have
too much cholesterol too much whatever
you got to change it they might have
been like hey dude you have so much fat
flowing through your [ __ ] veins if
you keep going this route eating fast
food you're gonna die and the doctor
said I might give you 10 years
dude come on man this is 10.4 dude
everybody would do this it might as well
say Dana visits a [ __ ] palm reader
and the palm reader game 10 10 years if
he doesn't change his lifestyle like
this come on dude
but if he gets them on track to get
healthy then it worked well she he did
yeah that's cool so this kind of sucks
Bobby green
um he failed that you sought a test for
DHEA which is like an over-the-counter
thing that you can buy which I think
Leota Machida was that was the same
thing that he did yeah because he said
he just wasn't paying attention to those
he said his girl got from from Walmart
here's what I knew he's [ __ ] when he
was well I was listening to a doctor on
YouTube
okay
so he says I'm crushed I'm like what the
[ __ ] I had no idea I was doing wrong
that there was any premise to that to
what I was doing I would never try to
like but then why would you take it Bob
if you didn't think there was any
benefits why would you take I know
uh he goes I would never even think
about those things I never even looked
at the site to know why it's banned and
what is not I don't give a [ __ ] because
I don't pay attention you got to pay
attention though oh yeah you thought out
there that's a bummer though yeah I
wonder how long the expansion they're
gonna give him it says one to two years
which would be so long [ __ ] you yeah
[ __ ] you especially at his age and they
noticed it because it says I heard that
there was abnormal abnormalities in the
testosterone levels so that's how they
pinpointed it yeah it's a bummer to get
bust for that yeah over the counter I
already get bust for like that old
school like deck that's gonna get me
and speaking of drug testing we've
talked about this on the show before too
how Conor doesn't really get tested I
guess he hasn't been tested at all in
2022 and he's recovering and he's
getting jacked he's on a yacht and [ __ ]
yep
and usada just gave a very generic once
UFC athletes are enrolled in the test
program they're subjected to testing
even when not competing unless they are
notified the UFCU of the retirement
their contract is terminated or they
otherwise removed from the program in
the event of an athlete's friend you see
their character Main and you saw a
testing pool for six months before
they're permitted to compete
similar to World amp anti-doping
anti-the-cma Grant exemption to the
six-month written notice rule
how interesting is this how you know
this this whole usad of [ __ ] it's based
like the WWE right when you find out a
guy in the WWE gets busted for steroids
that's just them trying to get rid of
the guy that WWE come on dude
because remember the testing the WWE
runs it just so you guys know the UFC
the usada works for the UFC it's not a
outside commission like the Nevada
commission or California commission they
are literally employed by the UFC to do
this
so they can say don't test Conor
don't test this guy don't test this guy
you know outside that do your regular
[ __ ] so it's it's tough man that's tough
that's very tough you're not going to
test your most famous guy who's recovery
yeah I know but then you're gonna show
up at other Fighters room at 4am and
make them piss it's in the DHEA thing
too I know it's really weird
and then it's you know it says uh
uh
the UFC May Grant an exemption to the
six-month rent notice like with Brock
like Vada and those like legit testing
like you can't there's no you can't
Grant you an exemption to fight earlier
it's all murky Waters but again I'm full
of [ __ ]
uh this is okay this is a very long
video and it's very hard to digest
everything um the more this guy more
places more dates yeah
so he was talking about someone in the
someone found the testing levels of
Daniel Cormier when he fought Jon Jones
I think it was the first time how would
they find that I don't know it's in the
record somewhere
yeah yeah
and also get all the attention was on
Jon Jones they don't make that stuff
public
so I don't know uh yeah I don't know I'm
I'm I have skeptical hippo eyes even on
that but let's see what he's saying oh
it's just way too long but basically
give me the summary uh basically Daniel
call me
big time
so he basically broke it down to he
doesn't they're overblowing this whole
thing and it could be something to where
Daniel cormier's weight you know he had
to drop a [ __ ] ton of weight something
to do with his weight loss hit the
protocols could have caused this oh so
it doesn't doesn't necessarily yes no DC
I'll play the very end of this so you
can see on your body for sure and for
him you know I just I imagine this is a
you know obviously a giant
misinterpretation of its testosterone
levels with the seven thousand for me
seeing this again at best he is using a
GnRH Agonist or some sort of Novel
compound sporadically seemingly but I
just don't think he would have done it
given that I don't see the consistency
in its use throughout the entirety of
this process because again like if
you're going to be trying to derive all
the benefits from that like are you
going to light yourself are you going to
pull it out you know before the
competition if you've already been
tested twice while you know you knew you
were [ __ ] using it like I would
imagine not and I imagine this is more
to do with his unique body composition
and the way he go about preparing for it
also says this was released on Reddit
but in Reddit can get certain you know
there's just people go on the Forum but
they can actually get get you know
whatever
certain documents from online and if
it's an official document
I don't know man that's sense of
material it'd be weird for them it even
says you're confidential yeah it'd be
weird for that to get released you know
unless the doc somebody in the doctor's
office scanned it and posted it that
could be the case it's weird with DC
right with DC like all these Fighters
that talk [ __ ] to him yes I was just so
it says Daniel Cormier wants Nate deals
to relax after fat [ __ ] comments
so uh yeah so DC came out and said long
story show well here's what he says
since Nate Diaz not finding hamzat was a
gift from God like that's literally the
best case scenario for him I I will sit
here and say this without a shadow of
doubt he was going to lose the hamzat
and it was he was going to lose bad as
much as Nate dismisses the guy he just
doesn't have the skill set to stop the
guy from doing what he does then Nate
says respect your OG you fat
[ __ ] it's interesting and then
he put Nathan relax it's interesting
right like Jorge came out against him
like just a lot of Fighters talk [ __ ]
about DC
and I think it's a case of you know DC's
top of the food chain Right light
heavyweight champ heavyweight champ
um if it was a smaller weight I don't
think they would do it but because he's
bigger they know the bigger guy's not
gonna do anything to them so they're
gonna fire shots at him but you talk on
that Lion's Tail enough that tiger if
that [ __ ] line turns around he's
gonna anybody who's talking [ __ ] about
DC Nate I would love to hear the
argument name one person
who's currently fighting that's taught
or hasn't that stocks [ __ ] about DC that
could beat him up I'd love to hear it
not one of them not one of them not a
single fighter that has taken a shot at
DC could actually do anything to DC if
DC wanted to even in that [ __ ] tight
suit that they put him in he would
destroy all of them inside that octagon
destroyed it destroyed but because he's
the Big Man on Campus people feel like
oh it's okay take shots at him he's a
big guy he's not going to do anything
which I I get it too you know what I'm
saying trust me I get that you don't
want to come off as a bully but I'm
telling you man anybody who's taking
shots at DC keep that same energy if DC
was being serious you guys would get
[ __ ] up but you know he's not gonna do
anything because he's a professional and
he works for the UFC commentating team
but if he wasn't
you guys wouldn't be taking taking [ __ ]
shots at him and also the only reason
taking shots at him is because he's
doing so well that's another reason
they're taking shots at him you know
it's gonna get traction if you talk [ __ ]
about DC but uh I would love to see if
people keep that kept that same 21st and
talk [ __ ] about [ __ ] Diaz right Jorge
maswell there's been other guys to take
shots at DC Tony man he beat every
everybody I just listed he beat up all
at the same time if he wanted to but you
know Daniel's smart professional gentle
soul and he's gonna be like okay dude
now he'll defend himself like this like
dude calm the [ __ ] down but if DC got
serious you ain't keep pulling out
Lion's Tail be careful what you asked
for because if DC wanted to twist every
single one of your necks off but he
doesn't you guys keep taking shots at
him yeah I mean DC lately before he's
more kind of like um more politically
correct but now he's starting to open up
and just be completely honest about
himself so guys get mad no one's the
only people more sensitive than Fighters
are Comics but they're very similar so
if you say anything about a comic say
anything about a fighter especially a
fighter they're gonna take it personal
and they fire shots at you all good I
would love to see keep that same energy
keep pulling on that Lion's Tail man you
better pray to God that line in the suit
don't turn around you boys would all be
in trouble remember when DC was uh in
the octagon with Duron win after he lost
yeah I told you he's another no no the
other guys the other guy he was like
whoa young man
yeah he's like you can see he would kick
his ass right yeah he was like you
better chill the [ __ ] out yeah I don't
want this fight for him he's like
where's this energy coming from and the
guy just now you're lucky he's a you
know he's a calm good dude he's mentally
stable that's another fighter with a
little splash of CT you boy you might
have won that fight you can get [ __ ]
up afterwards
yeah
all right um so Eddie Hearn is suing
Jake Paul for 100 million dollars
because he claims Jake claims there was
fight fixing against the I think two
fights so the Amanda Serrano one with
the Katie Taylor one and he's also
insinuating that one of the judges might
have been paid off for the USIC Joshua
thing because it was just
yeah
um the problem with this is you know
Jake being from YouTube talks a lot of
[ __ ] gets a lot of attention for it but
when you mess with a guy like Eddie
Hearn where that's his business where
this would put such a black guy in his
business and Eddie Hearn has all the
money if there's a lawsuit against you
they're gonna come for you man this is
going to cost him some money it's not
good I still think your man Serrano won
the fight
um
and then you see this judge Glenn
Feldman who has the biggest gap between
Taylor and Serrano everyone pretty much
had to draw a draw or that Amanda won
but there's that this judge Glenn Glenn
Feldman who scored in such a big gap for
Taylor gave rounds that Amanda clearly
won then this judge gun Feldman shows up
in Saudi and scores Anthony Joshua win
over USIC which is insane everyone who
watched that fight it's not a split
decision usik had a runaway Victory
clearly won the fight the judge Glenn
Feldman gives it to Anthony Joshua it's
like a repeated crime here step of [ __ ]
I'm going to call out here in boxing
because it's [ __ ] clearly this guy's
getting paid money by matchroom box
that's where he [ __ ] up see if he was
said clearly this guy's getting paid
money and then walked off he's good but
to call out mastering boxing matchroom
boxing which is Eddie hearn's promotion
that's what he [ __ ] up and these boys
can come after you man because that's
the biggest black guy 100 million dollar
loss now here's the thing is Jake Paul
right yes he is 100
the the the [ __ ] box and it's one of
the reasons boxing is ruined you look at
the Canelo Triple G first fight you look
there's a lot of [ __ ] in boxing ton
of [ __ ] boxing so Jake Paul's right
but the thing is you know when he calls
it like he sees it these boys are gonna
come after you
now I'm saying he's right as far as
boxing being corrupt especially when it
comes to judging I'm not saying Eddie
Hearn okay this judge in her matchroom
boxing is paying the judges there you go
I don't know who's paying the judges
somebody is
Jake Paul's right on that the corruption
boxing is real as he gets yes one of the
biggest issues in boxing
alrighty next one Hamza shimayev
uh he just posted this like he's moving
up to 185.
somebody probably got his hair the USC
gun is there was like Hey dude this 178
happened we can't keep banking on you
and then go you know I like it because
uh you know obviously Izzy has a tough
fight against Pierre coming up and
everyone's on Pierre's nuts which you
guys are [ __ ] crazy but
um it gets more blood at 185 170 stacked
170 be fine with harms out or not 85
could use some fresh blood harms that's
gonna be a real promise I'll be so much
fun yeah Hamza Izzy that's a great
[ __ ] fight
great fight
uh what do you think of this Scott Coker
mentioned that he'd want Anderson Silva
versus fader Fedor Emelianenko
um
no Fredo wants one more let's see
Anderson Silva looks against Jake Paul I
know Anderson's doing the Jake ball
fight and he's doing a Jujitsu
competition like Saudi Arabia or Abu
Dhabi shortly after so he's pretty
active two old dudes going at it you
know I'd watch it two legends it's very
bellators
two legends if it's their last fight but
I'm not like chomping at the bit to see
it let's see let's see how instant looks
against Jake because that fight sure as
[ __ ] ain't happening what if anything
gets
chance this could happen what if he gets
knocked cold by Jake Paul would you want
to see him against Fedor
you know
I think it's like totally that's what
I'm saying it's flat line yeah that'd be
tough
yeah
a cool fight a quick update on chill I
mean I thought this was already done
ready the whole lawsuit thing okay so
now he has two additional um mystery
misdemeanor battery charges dropped
so Chelsea has two of his six 12
millimeter battery counts dropped after
alleged Hotel scaffold so there's still
four outstanding
that whole thing is very suspect all the
way around yeah for you ever been to
Four Seasons there's cameras everywhere
goddamn CIA Hotel there's cameras
everywhere
alrighty uh this is a little older but I
thought it was interesting Muhammad
Ali's grandson he's assigned to pfl
and that's him right there he kind of
looks like a
bought a heart I think yeah right does
he ever so he signed with pfl how many
amateur fights does he have
stuck
he looks like Middle Eastern yeah yeah
that's uh so his mom is I think white I
think I forgot
biaggio Ali Walsh
so they sent him an amateur contract
oh I didn't read that part
1-1
um
that's cool
yeah
yeah he doesn't have a lot of fights two
fights two amateur fights one-on-one
we'll see
need some time to get going you know
yeah you're right I'm sure culture
amateur contract I didn't know yeah why
would even have amateur and then his
brother Nico Ali is The Undefeated
professional boxer
there you go makes sense
and oh this is a quick update too
oh damn that's a real watch yeah that's
a Daytona those are worth some money so
you remember Drake's promised them
watches and he only gave one yeah at the
time so finally Molly got hers God damn
and that is a that's not like a
Submariner or date Master Yacht-Master
that is a Daytona that's a real deal
Holyfield Rolex damn those puppies are I
mean you can't even get them at MSRP
that's an expensive [ __ ] watch that
is the Rolex to get on Drake oh yeah
it's dope which one is your gold one
that's the Submariner Submariner they're
cool it ain't a Daytona Daytona's like
creme de La Creme right now
good for [ __ ] Molly the meatball huh
uh check this out real quick tell me if
this is good power that he made it on
SportsCenter uh Yuri cherna brofkin
[Music]
Jesus Christ
doing something right
oh I'd love to see him just [ __ ] up Ryan
down with that
I play hard cold potassium just hook
Town's body like that
yeah this guy's a freak clearly Russian
yeah yep there you go yeah hell yeah you
look good okay I can't tell what it's
like you know my legs [ __ ] but it's a
bag yeah it doesn't
oh this is Mayweather's body yeah he
knocks out let's just play this 40 pound
difference what are you doing fighting a
guy with experience even though it's 40
pounds what the [ __ ] you thinking true
it's mod in the way he approached it
just terrible boom
oh you told me the bouncer for Floyd
Mayweather can't fight away a lot of
times they're just big guys you know I
don't know what people are thinking well
it's like when I was with Logan Paul's
team like Logan Paul's security was all
Titan Championship professional MMA
fighters and Floyd had his team just
these giant big dudes and uh Logan was
like Hey you think my security beat up
Floyd security like in a heartbeat one
of your guys take out two other guys I
mean you want real Fighters man it's
security you want just big guys if [ __ ]
hits the fan [ __ ] a big guy
big guys can hold people back but they
can't do anything other than that right
for a common person the big guy yeah
they're going to scare him away from
doing anything but you know you want you
want Fighters yeah Logan did it right he
hit the real deal hit black belts and
[ __ ] that's what you want oh yeah
and I think this is the last one Floyd
Mayweather has another excitation
another [ __ ] innocent dude no so this
guy oh he is innocent I guess but he's
uh ksi's younger brother sure YouTuber
sure nice YouTubers November something's
going on too you know what I'm saying
there's a lot about fights it's just
[ __ ] just like yeah I'll do it yeah
just such a weird career choice to me I
mean I know it's easy money
okay
he's fighting that okay let's go bro I
know yeah I guess let's go
hold on Mark just sent something
I'm seeing this
oh oh good sprawl by the criminal
oh
oh gosh whoa this cop camp
oh well first of all the guy is fighting
the UFC should pflg [ __ ] what they tase
them I thought they shot him
they shot him no look looks like a taser
Jesus Christ is yellow looking those
cops can pfl only sign that gun amateur
that dude was swinging is that it chin
that's it
save that for finding the kid mark
uh that's it so you got uh the triple
header this weekend you have won
Championship the card I'm most excited
for won championships
Gem of a fighter Andrew Lee is going for
the double champ champ Angela Lee versus
the punching Panda Nan it's the rubber
match they're uh you know last time uh
lee lost she went up in weight but now
um you know it's it's at straw weight so
this is Angela Lee is the chosen one
there I'm taking my girl Angelique via
submission submission she sure got it
done last time but that [ __ ] punching
Panda just wouldn't tap and then she was
tired and then you got the featherweight
uh kickboxing going down that's the
co-main event and then the other thing
I'm most excited for is you have the
flyweight submission grappling World
Championship Mikey versus they have a
history together and just for Jitsu in
general it's a big deal also one of my
favorite stamp Fair attacks Beast she's
also fighting on there so the whole
thing uh 5 p.m Pacific time and that's
on Amazon Prime one championship's
coming over baby you guys should get on
it now and also if you like big boys
they have the heavyweight kickbox and
World Grand Prix kicks off some Monsters
uh you have the return of say yid
um it's khabib's close friend training
partner a lot of people think he's the
next chosen one it's khabib's super
close friend you know could be his
friends makachev and khabib they grew up
like Karen goats up mountains this kid's
no different and he's khabib's training
partner everyone thinks he's the next uh
big thing so there's a lot to be excited
about man a lot to be excited about
Andrew Lee hopefully she gets it done
she's been on food truck you haven't
seen that she's an absolute Gem of a
person go watch the food truck right now
and then shout out to Mikey
um hopefully you get to get gets it done
again Sousa for the one flyweight
submission grappling Championship so get
you some man that's on uh Amazon Prime
at 5 PM Pacific on Saturday and then the
US he also has a Fight Night the main
event to Tasty one with MacKenzie Dern
versus John that's a fun one
um and the rest card's all right uh the
funnest one on there you got olanik
versus uh latifi that's a fun one
Jessica paniere's fighting as well uh
Joaquin Silva's fighting you have uh
Kristoff versus Brendan Allen chapter
Brendan Allen great name
um yeah not the UFC's the worst card of
the of them of the weekend let's be
honest one Championship is pretty tasty
Bellator is pretty stacked so for your
main card on Showtime yet Patricio
pitbull versus Adam BoRics great [ __ ]
fight AJ McKee Spike My Boy Aaron Picos
fighting Jeremy Kennedy that's a good
tough test for Aaron Pico any of Juan
Archuleta former world champion versus
Enrique barzola you have JJ Wilson
um good fights man Bellator is bringing
it this weekend on Showtime but make
sure you go and watch uh one
Championship on Amazon Prime 5pm Pacific
the diamond the one the chosen one Angel
Lee is fighting her Trilogy fight
against the punching Panda get you some
man uh and then Thursday I hit the road
Boston is this Thursday Friday Saturday
one show Thursday two shows Friday two
shows Saturday get your tickets we've
never not sold out Boston I'm sure as
[ __ ] about to start now Boston
Thursday Friday Saturday and then
October 13th through the 15th we're in
San Jose San Jose Improv Salt Lake City
October 20th through the 22nd at the
Wise Guys one of my favorite clubs in
the nation and then we end October in
Calgary Calgary at the rooftop October
27th that is a Thursday and then we're
going to add a show on the 28th which is
a Friday rooftop downtown Calgary come
get you some Calgary but this week
Boston whose car are we taking we're
going Thursday Friday Saturday Boston
get you some tickets at thickboy.com
thank you guys for watching Thanks for
liking subscribing doing all the
freaking things
um love you guys man hope you have a
good week hopefully it's a good way to
start your week and uh I will see you
guys next time I'm out I'm just gonna
shut her down everywhere in this fight
everyone is going to see the best
version of me
Supreme welcome
[Music]
[Music]
the trilogy match we've all been waiting
for
if you're into thick boys
like subscribe comment
and God bless America well that's not my
big one just kidding